new fortnite came out two weeks ago new
Call of Duty came out last week I'm
going to rank my top five celebrities SL
athletes that are the best Partners to
have those games first is quo cuz I be
playing the game with quo a lot man be
playing 2K in Call of Duty number two
Brun
li who else should I play with oh Juju
Smith Shuster yeah I play fortnite with
shador sometimes he suck though y'all
ain't going to lie he's do oh I know who
play the game that I would play with
carony towns I play with cat and Tar
Hill that's who I play with oh I should
have used Co Prim but Co Prim don't play
games you got to play with somebody that
play
games